So why might we care to do this, Michael? So,
there's a bunch of reasons but really it boils down
to two. One is really about human beings and the
other is really about machines and machine learning algorithms. And the
first one really boils down to what I'll just call
knowledge discovery, alright. It is often useful when you're thinking about
a set of data in a problem, to be able
to interpret the features. To figure out well, which subset features
that I've been keeping track of say, when then
I'm using on my sensors actually matter. And so really
the feature selection problem for what other reasons you might
think of doing it or often for interpretability and for
insight. So it turns out that of the 1,000
features that I keep track of only a few matter.
Maybe only 10 of them matter for doing solving some
problem of prediction. So let's think about our spam case
for example. There are lots and lots and lots of features that
we might care about in spam case, but it may turn out
that after we do some kind of analysis that it really all
boils down to something like whether you're getting mail from a Nigerian
prince, for example. And some of these things that you thought mattered.
Don't seem to matter. For for the purposes of solving some problem
or, or for doing prediction. And, so, often, this is a very,
very useful thing to do. You do this kind of thing all
the time, Michael. Actually, if you go back
and you look at some of the things that
we have been giving for examples. You come up
with problems and features taht are, for example, visible
to two dimensions as opposed to three or
four or five becdause it's easy for you to
visualize them and to understand them. And for students
to understand how the algorithms work in two d.
>> Hm that makes sense.
>> Does that all make sense? Okay. So that's one thing and there's, and
this really should not be underestimated. People
tend to ignore this a lot in the,
in the, at least in the machine learning field, much less in the data
mining field but this really is a sort of key and an important issue.
But there's another reason we might care about if it's algorithmic and that is
the curse of dimensionality. So do you
remember what the Curse of Dimensionality is Michael?
>> Yeah, as you add more features you may need
exponentially need more data to kind of fill out the space.
>> The Curse of Dimensionality says that the amount of data
that you need grows exponentially in the
number of features that you have. So it'd
be really nice if you could have
fewer features. So the problem of feature selection
helps us, hopefully at least in a, in a nice world. To go from a
whole bunch of features to just a few
features, thus making the learning problem actually easier.
>> [LAUGH] Looks a little bit like a smile, an alien smiley face now.
>> That's right. So we came with an alien frowny face
in the beginning and [LAUGH] then we [INAUDIBLE] with an alien
smiley face. Okay, so you buy these reasons Michael?
>> Yeah, I like how you managed to, you know if X
is the input space here, you've managed to map X to Y.
>> Michael uses the feature transformation function known as the pun.
>> Mmm.
>> That's really good, I like that. Okay. Anyway. Okay,
so let's keep all this in mind when we're talking
about all the algorithms that we're talking about in this
lesson, and even in the future transformation lesson. The goal
is to take, be able to use, in general, a bunch of features, because
you think they might all be important, and then apply some kind of algorithm to
get to just the important features. And if you can do that well, then not
only will you understand your data better,
But you'll also have an easier learning problem.
>> Got it.